النظام لا يريد ذلك ويريد
إسكاته ويريد إسكات
المعارضة
التي لم يخبرونا بها عن سبب
اختطافه ولم يتم القبض عليه.
تم اختطافه
ونقله إلى إيران.
أخذ أدويته في وقت متأخر
في وقت ما كان يسعل بشدة ،
لذلك كنا قلقين من أنه
قد يكون مصابًا بفيروس كورونا
للأسف نحن لا نعرف سوى القليل جدًا عن
الحالة القانونية وصحة والدي
عندما غادر من هنا كان يعاني من
مرحلة متقدمة من
مرض باركنسون الذي  منهك للغاية ، كان
عليه أن يأخذ الأدوية كل ثلاث
ساعات
ولا أعرف ما إذا كانوا يعطونه
الدواء الذي يحتاجه وإذا تم
إعطاؤه في الوقت المحدد
كان مصابًا بداء السكري وأمراض القلب حول
قضيته القانونية ، فنحن لا نعرف
شيئًا  لأن محامينا غير
مسموح له بالاطلاع على القضية
ولم يُسمح لأحد برؤيته لمدة 11
شهرًا
لم يخبرونا عن سبب
اختطافه ولم يتم القبض عليه وتم
اختطافه
واقتياده  إلى إيران لكنه كان مستهدفًا
منذ 10 سنوات من قبل النظام الإسلامي
، لقد حاولوا تقييمه في
الولايات المتحدة في عام
2009 وحاولوا
اختطافه وإخراجه خارج البلاد
لمدة 10 سنوات حتى الآن والدي الموقع
لـ  جماعة معارضة وهو
يتحدث علنا على هذا ال
وقع ويعطي الشعب الإيراني صوتا وا
نظام الإسلامي لا يريد ذل
ويريد إسكاته وي
يد إسكات المعارضة أه
ن خلال الخطف وإرهابهم أي
فاوضات تكون  يجري أم
ينبغي أن تضع حقوق الإنسان في المرتبة الأولى
أجنبي أجنبي